right on 8 news now is sponsored by our
community pride partners
finley automotive group southwest
medical part of optum care and silver
state schools credit union
all right welcome back to las vegas now
the following segment
is sponsored by finley automotive group
there's a special place in town that
turned 30 this week
and finley automotive group is helping
them celebrate here's how
[Music]
we are celebrating a big anniversary
here at the las vegas natural history
museum this week you're turning 30.
congratulations
july 12 1991 and now to celebrate of
course we have tyler quarter
from the finley automotive group who
does so much for the community how are
we celebrating well so in honor of the
30th anniversary we thought we would
come over and feature the las vegas
natural history museum we're doing it
here in the findlay automotive marine
life exhibit
and also bringing a little money a
little donation for the
for the museum to help them in their
mission and uh we've got marilyn here
who marilyn has been the executive
director here
since the beginning for 30 years but
she's going to hang it up this month so
kate is here who's going to be taking
her spot
and we're just really happy to renew our
sponsorship of the museum
awesome and congratulations since 1991
you've created such an important piece
to our community so thank you
and congratulations on your new chapter
and you too kate
it's time to take over and fill some big
shoes so how's this money going to help
you
oh my gosh this is a huge help for the
museum
we are so thankful for findlay
continuing their partnership with us
this will help support not only the
marine life animals in this gallery
but the educational value that they
offer for every visitor to the museum
absolutely and speaking of education
tyler so tell us more about
the marine life findlay sponsorship a
lot of people don't realize there's 150
live animals here in the museum
so there's a lot of educational
opportunities and one of them here in
the marine life exhibit is the
interactive shark exhibit where you can
come in and learn a little bit about the
history of sharks
it's gonna work there it goes and yeah
it
works you through and uh it's a great
educational opportunity especially for
kids
of course and that's why we're going to
bring it over to you now so what are we
learning here
give us a little example sure so in this
exhibit they're able to explore the
evolution of sharks over the years so as
you can see
from the cast behind us here megalodon
was this massive
shark in the ocean in prehistoric times
and then over time we see that
dinosaur dna elephant dna shark dna
have created the creatures that we know
and love today
cool now tell everybody out at home
right now why they should come down and
visit
the las vegas national history museum
well first and foremost we've been
serving the community for 30 years now
we offer fun from the marine life
gallery sponsored by findlay
all the way to africa egypt we have a
working paleontology lab there's really
something for everybody in the family to
enjoy
and hopefully be inspired by here at the
museum absolutely well thank you guys so
much congratulations on the ten thousand
dollars you guys obviously do so much
and we appreciate you at findlay
automotive group
so much fun over there